اهلا بكم الى هذه النشره الموجزه اتخذ
طاقم الوزاريه الاسرائيلي والمصغر سلسله
قرارات عقبيه ردا على عمليتي القدس وتضمنت
القرارات واغلاقه منزلي منفذ عمليه القدس
على الفور تمهيدا لهدمه وحرمان عائلتي
منفذين عمليات من الحق في التامين الوطني
منح بطاقات الهويه الخاصه بسكان القدس
لعائله منافذ العمليه كما قرر المجلس
العلمي المصغر توسيعه وتسريع نطاق منحي
تراخيص الاسلحه الناريه للاسرائيليين
وتعزيز الاجراءات الامنيه في المستوطنات
وتعزيز قوات الشرطه والجيش لجميع عمليات
نمليه وحمالات لجمع ما وصفها بالاسلحه غير
المشروعه
وكان رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بين ايميل
نتنياهو قد قال خلال الاجتماع ان الرد على
العمليات الاخيره في القدس سيكون قويا
وسريعا ودقيقه اوضح ان اسرائيل لا تسعى
لتصعيد لكن قواتها منتشره ومعززه وجاهزه
للتعامل مع كل احتمال واي طارق
ردنا
ودقيقا من يحاول المسافه بين سنضربه من
يساعده لقد نفذنا عمليات اعتقال واسعه ضد
مؤيد الارهاب ومساعدهم والمحردين لقد
نشرنا القوات وعززنا القوات وذلك على
جبهات المختلفه سنهادم منازل المخربين
باجراء سريع وذلك لجبايه ثمن اضافي من
اولئك الذين يؤيدون الارهاب وهذه العمليه
بدات امس وهي في ذروتها الان
حراسه مستوطنه اكاديميه شرق مدينه قلقيليه
في شمال الضفه الغربيه شابا فلسطينيا
بينما كان يسير على طريق الالتفافيه حول
المستوطنه التي يعيش فيها وزير الماليه و
زعيم حزب الصهيونيه الدينيه الشهيد
الفلسطيني
وفي اريحا اقتحمت عشرات ولاليات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه مخيم عقبه جبر للبحث عن منفذ
عمليه اطلاق نار قربه مستوطنه جنوبيه
المدينه واكد جيش الاحتلال عدم وقوع اي
اصابات في الهجوم واشار الى ان قوته مشطه
المنطقه بحثا عن المهاجم ورجح جيش
الاحتلال السلاح المهاجم تعطل في الطره
لان يلوث
على معسكر وحاجز حواره للجيش الاسرائيلي
جنوبيه مدينه نابلس في الضفه الغربيه قالت
لنا افراد مجموعه سحبوا بسلام بعد تنفيذ
العملي
في ردود الفعل الفلسطينيه حمله حركه فتح
الحكومه الاسرائيليه النتائج المترتبه على
سياستها التي وصفتها
وقال المتحدث باسم حركه فتحا حكومات
الاحتلال المتعقبه اغلقت كل الابواب وتركت
باب المواجهه والقتل والاعتقالات وانتهاك
المقدسات جانبي دار رئيس المكتب السياسي
لحركه حماس اسماعيل
وشعوب الحره الى تدخل الوقت
وما وصفا بحكومه اليمين الفاشل
الى التصعيد وان المواجهه لن تبقى داخل
سجون جاءتها قالت حركه الجهاد الاسلامي في
بياننا المقاومه تحيه وبقيه ان عمليتي
القدس ضربتها المنظومه الامنيه والعسكريه
الاسرائيليه
وبينما تتجه الانظار الى الزياره المرتقبه
لوزير الخليجيه الامريكيه انطوني بلينكن
الى المنطقه يواصلوا مدير المخابرات
المركزيه الامريكيه وليامبرز اتصالاته ضمن
جوله تتضمن محادثات مع مسؤولين اسرائيليين
قبل الانتقال الى رام الله للقاء قياده
سياسيه وامنيه فلسطينيه
مع اسرائيل ورؤيه حكومه
بشان التعاطي مع الفلسطيني
اعلانات وزاره الدفاع الايرانيه احباطاه
هجوم بثلاث طائرات مسيره صغيره استلفت احد
المصانع العسكريه التابعه لها بمحافظه
اسوان
المضاده
الى انفجار اثنتين منها وان الاضرار
اقتصرت على سقف المصنع دون الاضرار
بالمعدات كما اكدت وزاره الدفاع الايراني
ضربته خمس درجات فاصله تسعه على مقياس
ريختر مدينه اخوي بالمحافظه اذربيجانه
الغربيه في شمال غرب ايران اصفر عن وفاه
ثلاثه اشخاص واصابه نحو 440 اخرين وقال
الجمعيه الهلال الاحمر الايرانيه انها
ارسلت عددا من فرق الانقاذ وسيارات
الاسعاف الى المناطق المنكوبه فيما اعلنت
السلطات المحليه في المحافظه فتح المدارس
وصلت الرياضيه امام السكان بعد تسجيل عدد
من الهزات الارتداديه
نقل مراسل الجزيره عن مصادر عسكريه
اوكرانيا من الوضع في بلده اوجلدار بشرق
اوكرانيا صعب لكنه تحت السيطره وقالت
المصادر من القوات الاوكرانيه تتصدى
لمحاولات تقدم القوات الروسيه وتكبدها
خسائر كبيره في اوجليدار
في المقابل وصفت السلطات الماليه لروسيا
في دنيا تدور بالقرب من اجلدار بالعنيفه
وعلى لسان القوات الروسيه تتمركزت في
الاجزاء الشرقيه والجنوبيه الشرقيه
على الكره المحيطه بالمدينه
ولا مستشار ورئاسه الاوكرانيه مثل لابدليك
ان اوكرانيا تجري مفاوضات مع شركيها بجانب
توفير الطائرات وصواريخ بعيده المدى في
اسرع وقت واكد في تصريحات المتلفزه حاجه
اوكرانيا الى تلك الطائرات لحمايه
المدرعات المقدمه من قبل الشركاء اوضح ابو
داليا كان بلاده بحاجه الى تدمير مخازن
القوات الروسيه والقبائل في المدفعيه لان
هذاتهم الرئيسيه